- The number B is five less than twice
the number C.
Let me write that down.
So B is equal to five less than
twice the number C.
So that's two times C minus five.
It's five less than
two times the number C.
The product of B and C is 45.
So I could write that as
B times C is equal to 45.
Which of the following pairs of equations
could be used to find
the values of B and C?
So let's see.
So this one we have 45 is equal to BC,
45 is equal to BC,
so these are contenders.
This one has 45C is equal to B.
Well that's like, this
is a different equation.
If you divided both sides by C,
you would have 45 is equal to B over C,
so we can knock this one out.
This one has 45C is equal to B.
Well once again, 45C equals B,
we can knock that one out.
This one has 45 is equal to BC.
So now we can just focus on
the first of these equations.
So let's see.
B is equal to two minus 5C.
No, it should be 2C minus five.
So we can knock that one out.
B is equal to 2C minus five.
Well that's exactly what I wrote here.
BC is equal to 45.
That's exactly what I wrote here.
Wrote over here, so this
is going to be our choice.
So we can verify that this
last one isn't going to work.
B is equal to two times C plus five.
Well, if you distribute the two,
that's like saying that B is equal to 2C
plus 10, which is clearly different
than this first equation
that I wrote up here.
So we can knock that out as well.